Guten Morgen, Andre.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Willkommen zurück in der Netzneutralität.
Ach echt, ist hier alles gut?
Alles total super. Logbuch Netzpolitik, die 99. Ausgabe, noch sind wir zweistellig, große Spannung, was wohl beim nächsten Mal passiert. Ja, und da Linus aber immer noch weg ist, haben wir uns Verstärkung geholt, nämlich Andre Meister. Hallo.
Hallo, ich dachte ich bin hier zu 100.
Ja, ne, ja, mal gucken, wie du dich bewährst. Ne, du warst aber weg.
Ich war eine Weile weg, weg aus Deutschland, nicht ganz weg aus dem Internet, weil das gibt es irgendwie auf großen Teilen dieses runden Erdballs.
Zumindest in Spuren.
Ja, in Spuren. Ich war in Südas Asien, hab den Winter in Schurz verbracht. Markus hat das als Strandforschung bezeichnet. Aber tatsächlich war ich erstaunt, wie viel WLAN es überall gibt. Gerade so in Thailand, da gibt es WLAN an jedem 7-Eleven-Supermarkt, der wirklich an jeder Ecke ist. Kostenlos, man muss sich registrieren, und man darf halt nur eine halbe Stunde mit derselben Mac surfen, aber dann ändert man die Mac, und es gibt kostenlose WLAN in jedem. Also ich war tatsächlich erstaunt von, ich war in sieben Ländern, und in fast allen gab es Internet, selbst im letzten Dorf in Laos. Ja, es geht voran. Außer Myanmar, da sieht es ein bisschen strange aus, da kostet, da ist die Internetpenetration in der Bevölkerung so bei 2-3% oder so, weil die so arm sind. Teilweise vor zwei Jahren hat eine SIM-Karte, eine 2G-SIM-Karte noch um die 1000-2000 Dollar gekostet.
Eine SIM-Karte?
Ja, bei einem Einkommen von so 150 Dollar oder so, wenn überhaupt. Ne, nur die zu kaufen, da war noch nicht mal ein Tarif mit drin.
Ich meine, das Einkommen ist 150 Dollar im Monat.
Naja, es kommt drauf an, wo, ungefähr im Monat. Mittlerweile kosten die SIM-Karten, also es kommt drauf an, wo ich gefragt habe, weil die meisten wussten nicht so genau, was ich meine hier mit 3G und Internet und so. Ich glaube, eine 2G-Karte kostet derzeit so 200 Dollar, aber Tendenz rapide sinkend. Die haben gerade Ausschreibungen. Die ganzen internationalen Telekom-Konzerne rennen in die Bude ein und wollen dort ein Mobile-Network aufstellen. Aber im Rest von Südostasien, Singapur und so, da ist 4G ohne WLAN.
Mehr WLAN als in Berlin sozusagen.
Mehr WLAN als in Berlin, unglaublich. Das ist dann nicht immer frei und unüberwacht. Das ist es hier auch nicht.
Aber die haben natürlich auch mehr Strand.
Das war ja der eigentliche Grund.
Wenn wir mehr Strand hätten, wäre wahrscheinlich auch mehr WLAN.
Aber manchmal sieht das Internet tatsächlich so aus, wie wir uns das hier in den Hochauvorstellungen haben. Ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass hier alles gut ist, auch wenn ihr letztens mal mit Thomas über die Entscheidung des Europaparlamentes zur Netzneutralität berichtet habt. Hier wird Skype geblockt, hier wird BitTorrent geblockt im Mobile-Network. In der EU wird teilweise auch ein Festnetz-Internet eingegriffen. Ja, so sieht das auch in anderen Ländern aus. Ich hatte da mal ein Bild oder zwei vertwittert von so Mobile-Tarifen. Da steht dann tatsächlich drauf, du kriegst Basis-Internet-Serve-Clicky-Browser für so und so viele, je nachdem Land, Malaysia, Ringgit oder Thailand, Baht. Und wenn du dann auch Facebook, Twitter oder so was willst oder WhatsApp, dann zahlst du halt nochmal so und so viel Geld mehr.
Du hast da immer mal wieder so ein paar Fotos gepostet, die müssen wir auch unbedingt noch mitten in die Show Notes aufnehmen. Das fand ich dann schon wirklich ex- also es ist wirklich genauso dieses Horrorbild mit, ja man wählt sich quasi so die Dienste zusammen und für den Rest muss man dann halt nochmal extra zahlen, weil es interessiert ja normalerweise keinen.
Genau, der Peter Pixer hat das mal zusammen verblockt, können wir gerne verlinken. Ist zwar nur in Anführungsstrichen mobile, aber so sieht es aus. Und da kommen wir hin, wenn wir das nicht stoppen.
Okay, aber jetzt im Festnetz oder so was mit WLAN oder so was hast du sowas nicht gesehen?
Ich habe sowas nicht gesehen, ich habe jetzt aber auch keinen Festnetzanschluss beantragt. Im Festnetz gab es ganz andere Probleme, so wie gerade Vietnam hat eine mega Zensur-Infrastruktur. Das war dann eher lustig, die internationalen Touris dabei zu beobachten. Ey, mein Facebook geht nicht. Und ich so, ja, willkommen in der echten Welt, hier VPN oder hier Tour, das hilft. Also, und Vietnam ist auch am meisten überwacht. Die haben eine mega Inhaltsvorratsdatenspeicherung. Dann werden da immer mal Blogger verhaftet und so. Also, krasse Anti-Free Speech-Regelungen. Das sind dann eher die Probleme, mit denen Locals kämpfen. Und nicht so sehr tatsächlich, dass jedes Bit, jedes Paket gar nicht angeguckt wird. Da gibt es DPI. Also, teilweise haben die Vietnamesen versucht, mit meinem VPN zu interferieren.
Also, DPI, die Packet Inspection, das direkte reinschauen in die Pakete auf Routerebene. Das heißt, nicht mal mit deinem VPN kamst du immer durch, oder?
Nee, teilweise haben die tatsächlich dann beim VPN-Aufbau TCP Reset-Pakete versucht, mit reinzumachen und die Session zu unterbrechen. Dann musste dann halt irgendwie... Irgendwas geht immer. Und auch nicht jeder ISP ist gleich. Mancher ISP bloggt Twitter, ein anderer bloggt Facebook. Das ist ein bisschen strange in Vietnam. Dann gehst du halt zum Wählern vom Hostel auf der Straße gegenüber, und dann geht's dann wieder, oder so.
Also ohne den Basis-Kurs TCP-IP kann man heutzutage eigentlich überhaupt kein Traveler mehr sein.
Ja, oder man beschwert sich dann halt, mein Facebook geht nicht, und macht dann mal Urlaub ohne Internet, was vielleicht auch nicht so schlimm ist.
Ich wollte es ja jetzt nicht gleich so krass formulieren, ja. Dass die Leute sich auf einmal am Strand entspannen ohne Netz.
Aber tatsächlich habe ich den einen oder anderen Leuten wohl noch etwas über dieses Internet beigebracht.
Kann man sich damit vielleicht auch ganz gut durchschlagen, wenn man sonst keine Gaben hat. Das heißt, man fliegt einfach nach Südausasien und verdient sich sein Geld mit Internetzugangsbeschaffung für die anderen verzweifelten Touristen. Das wäre ja auch mal ein Business-Modell.
Noch habe ich das nicht als Business-Modell gesehen. Wir haben uns ja vor der Sendung unterhalten. Wir kennen tatsächlich den einen oder anderen Programmierer oder die anderen Programmiererinnen, die tatsächlich überall auf der Welt arbeiten können, weil sie ja Internet irgendwo einchecken. Und davon gibt es ein paar auch in dieser Ecke, von denen ich ein paar getroffen habe. Aber so Internet erklären, weiß nicht. Es gibt ein paar NGOs, die das machen. Die haben dann aber auch wieder Probleme, gerade so in Staaten wie Myanmar und Vietnam, die jetzt nicht nur nicht in der Spitzenrangliste der freien Meinungsäußerungen sind. Da sind dann NGOs, die so arbeiten, die müssen höllisch aufpassen, damit die Locals, denen sie was beibringen, nicht sofort in den Knast bringen und so. Da sind auch mal echt andere Sitten da. Ich habe, nee.
Also Kontakt, über die du reden darfst, meine ich.
Genau, mit Local-Gruppen, mit denen ich da war, habe ich tatsächlich jetzt nicht unmittelbar meine Arbeit von Internet-Freedom gemacht. Aber es ist durchaus, hier oder da habe ich mal Leute getroffen, die sich in ähnlichen Sphären bewegen. Aber das ist jetzt, glaube ich, nicht für On the Record.
Gut, dann schauen wir nochmal, was für On the Record so gedacht ist. Ist ja nicht so, dass nichts passiert wäre. Große Meldung, wir sind ein bisschen spät dran, aber dafür gut abgehangen, Rückblick auf europäischer Ebene. Da gab es ein erwartetes, wie auch trotzdem, wie ich finde, recht erfreuliches Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshofs, dem sogenannten EUGH, zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Da gab es ja im Vorfeld schon die, ja, vielbeachtete Vorlage der Staatsanwaltschaft. Ist das die richtige Bezeichnung?
Generalanwalt.
Genau. Und das ging ja schon so ein wenig in die Richtung. Und man konnte auch so ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen herauslesen, dass das Ganze doch zumindest inhaltlich grundsätzlich auch von der Entscheidung des Deutschen Verfassungsgerichts zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung inspiriert ist. Also so Tendenz, ja, wir sagen nicht, dass es generell unmöglich ist, aber wir stellen hohe Hürden auf. Jetzt ist das tatsächliche Urteil auch gefallen. Und es macht so den Eindruck, als ob es doch recht weitgehend ist. Aber manche sehen es auch anders.
Ja, zunächst müssen wir festhalten, das ist ein ganz großer Gewinn. Der EuGH ist in der Entscheidung noch über den Generalbundesanwalt, das Statement, was ihr ja ausführlich seziert habt, hinausgegangen. Und der hat tatsächlich die gesamte Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung für nichtig erklärt, ab sofort. Das ist ein riesiger Gewinn. Es gibt jetzt derzeit in Europa keine Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung, keine Verpflichtung mehr zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und das ist krass. Die Richtlinie gab es seit 2006. Wir haben damit mega gewonnen. Unsere Freunde vom AK-Vorrat Österreich und Digital Rights Ireland, die die Klagen angestrengt hat, weil die Klage, die der AK-Vorrat damals in Deutschland beim Bundesverfassungsgericht hatte, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat das leider nicht an den EuGH verwiesen, hätte das auch machen können. Jetzt haben uns Österreich und Irland gerettet. Das ist ein ganz, ganz großer Gewinn für die Netzszene, für die Überwachungskritiker in der EU. Das hätte ich vorher nicht gedacht, dass die Richtlinie kippen, und zwar sofort. Das hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht, doch das hat das Gesetz auch gekippt, und zwar auch sofort. Aber bei der Richtlinie?
Aber dass das ebenso auf europäischer Ebene auch möglich ist, denke auch, da war sich jetzt nicht unbedingt jeder so einig. Aber es ist ja nicht nur, dass die Richtlinie nichtig ist, damit entfällt ja nicht nur die Grundlage für viele bereits existierenden, lokale Gesetzgebungen in einzelnen europäischen Staaten, sondern im Prinzip wird ja damit auch gesagt, wenn ihr so etwas habt, dann widerspricht das dem europäischen Gedanken. Also müssten Sie im Prinzip all diese bereits beschlossenen Gesetze wieder zurücknehmen?
Schön wär's. Jetzt wird's tricky, weil wir beide keine Anwälte sind. Ja, nahe. Das Ruling liest sich stellenweise sehr gut, teilweise hat es dann aber auch so What-the-fuck-Momente. Staaten dürfen eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben. Das wollte ich schon in der E-Privacy-Richtlinie von 95 war die, glaube ich. Artikel 10 ist das, glaube ich, beschlossen. Und das war schon immer ein Problem. Dass Staaten sagen dürfen, unser Gesetz sagt, wir haben sechs Monate Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wir haben drei, wir haben zwei Jahre. Was es ja auch gibt in anderen EU-Staaten, was ja mal der eigentliche Grund, der eigentliche offizielle Grund für diese Vorratsdatenspeicherungs-Richtlinie war, zu sagen, wir vereinheitlichen das jetzt einmal alles. Es geht gar nicht so sehr um Terror, das können wir in der Öffentlichkeit so verkaufen, aber eigentlich ist das eine Binnenmarktregulierung. Wir wollen, dass Telekommunikationsanbieter überall gleiche Marktchancen haben, und deswegen soll das eine einheitliche Speisefrist geben. Die ganzen nationalen Gesetze, die teilweise vor der EU-Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung teilweise danach erlassen wurden, die verliehen jetzt durch dieses Urteil leider nicht unmittelbar ihre Gültigkeit. Der EuGH hat, soweit ich das als Nicht-Anwalt verstehe, geurteilt, dass die Richtlinie gegen die europäische Grundrechte-Karta verstößt, das aber nicht automatisch heißt, dass die nationalen Umsetzungsgesetze gegen die europäische Grundrechtskarta verstößt. Die müssen dann an ihren nationalen Grundrechten, was jeweils in den Verfassungen stehen haben, gemessen werden. Wir haben in Deutschland das Glück, wir haben derzeit kein Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetz. Alle 27 anderen EU-Staaten haben aber eins, und die werden wir wahrscheinlich leider nicht überall so schnell wegbekommen. Es gibt erste Ansätze, dass Schweden zum Beispiel gesagt hat, wir verklagen jetzt keine Provider, die das noch nicht umgesetzt haben, könnte man machen und so. Es wird aber jetzt einigen Druck leider in den einzelnen Mitgliedstaaten brauchen, um zu sagen, die Gesetze, die schon da sind, die nehmen wir jetzt wieder weg.
War es nicht auch so, dass Schweden auch schon Strafzahlungen geleistet hat an die EU oder hätte leisten müssen?
Schweden wurde auch wegen langer Nichtumsetzung zu Strafzahlungen verurteilt. Ob sie die geleistet haben, ist mir nicht ganz bekannt. Auf jeden Fall ist das eine der offenen Fragen jetzt nach dem Urteil, ob die noch geleistet werden müssen oder, falls schon Zahlungen erfolgt sind, ob es die Kohle jetzt eventuell zurückgibt.
Das gelte ja im Prinzip auch für Deutschland.
Das gilt im Prinzip auch für Deutschland, wenn Deutschland noch verurteilt werden würde für Nichtumsetzung. Das ist jetzt eher unwahrscheinlich. Die ganze Richtlinie gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Also sehr unwahrscheinlich. Auf jeden Fall ist damit ja auch in Deutschland das Argument entfallen. Die Reaktion in Deutschland war dann ja auch sehr bunt. Zunächst einmal gab es den Justizminister Heiko Maas, der schon am Anfang ein wenig dadurch aufgefallen ist, dass er meinte, so VDS und so muss ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt sein. Dann wurde er schnell von unserem neuen alten Innenminister wieder eingenordet. Und dann klang das erstmal nicht ganz so. Und dann zog er sich eben auf diese Position zurück mit, naja, mal gucken, was da so beschlossen wird. Und dann schauen wir mal. Jetzt ist die Entscheidung ja gekommen. Und dann meinte er dann auch erstmal so, naja, dann brauchen wir das ja jetzt auch nicht zu machen, weil die Koalitionsvereinbarung zwischen SPD und CDU sich ja nun explizit auf diese europäische Richtlinie bezog, die es eben jetzt so in der Form nicht mehr gibt. Aber andere sehen das wieder anders. Also die Polizei war auch gleich ganz schnell gesagt, jetzt ist ja alles klar, jetzt können wir ja endlich die VDS einführen.
Genau, wir danken Ihnen.
Und Ihre Logik hernehmen, weiß ich immer nicht so ganz genau.
Wir danken dem Gericht für die Klarstellung. Jetzt haben wir eine Plaupause, wie wir es richtig machen können. Ja, so hallo, hatten doch die Statements immer. Jeder bedankt sich und jeder ist fühlt sich selbstbestätigt. Im Endeffekt ist NAFU, Situation Normal, All Fucked Up, alles wie immer. Die Befürworter wollen die Fahrräder erst weiterhin, die Gegner lehnen die weiterhin ab. Mit denselben Argumenten, nur dass es jetzt das Argument, aber Brüssel sagt, wir müssen, jetzt nicht mehr gibt. Und es wird jetzt sowohl auf Bundesebene als auch auf EU-Ebene ein politischer Kampf, wieder eine politische Auseinandersetzung werden, um die Zukunft der Richtlinie und um die Zukunft einer deutschen Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Scheint aber jetzt zumindest aus dem Disput zwischen SPD und CDU jetzt erst mal so weit der Burgfrieden hergestellt worden zu sein, dass man sagt, in dieser Legislaturperiode gehen wir das nicht an.
Genau, das gab es vorgestern am Sonntag als Spiegelmeldung. Da sind aber nur irgendwie aus Regierungskreisen oder so, als Quelle gewesen. Es gibt jetzt kein Statement von Angela Merkel, wir machen keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und wir haben ja auch trotzdem letzte Woche nicht nur die Polizeigewerkschaften, sondern auch die SPD-Innenminister haben gesagt, danke für die Klarstellung. Jetzt wissen wir, wie wir eine richtige Vorratsdatenspeicherung Grundrechtsschonend machen können oder wie das immer bei denen heißt. Ja, die Befürworter wollen es weiterhin, die Gegner lehnen es weiterhin ab.
Interessanterweise geht ja die Debatte jetzt, also unsere frühere Justizministerin Sabine Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger muss man sagen, ist ja eigentlich in ihrer Position weitgehend bestätigt worden. Sie hat sich ja lange Zeit gegen die VDS gewährt. Aus all den Argumenten, die jetzt im Prinzip genauso vom EuGH, wie auch vorher schon vom Verfassungsgericht auch so gesehen wurden und ihr Handelsangebot in der Hinsicht war ja schon immer die sogenannte Quick-Freeze-Regelung, die kommt jetzt auch wieder ins Gespräch.
Den Vorschlag von der Frau Ministerin habe ich damals ziemlich verrissen und mit Quick-Freeze Plus war es da glaube ich nicht getan, weil das war eine 7-Tage-Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Sonst hat man ja nichts zum Einfrieren. War damals die Argumentation von ihr, geht einigen aus dem AK-Vorrat immer noch zu weit. Soweit sind wir jetzt in der deutschen Debatte noch nicht. Die haben jetzt erstmal den Schuss vor den Buch bekommen und müssen sich jetzt intern überhaupt erstmal klar werden, so wie gehen wir jetzt damit um. Wie sind die Mehrheitsverhältnisse? Was ist der politische Wille? Man könnte ja auch, wie wir bisher schon gesagt haben, dass man in Deutschland das nicht umsetzen soll, ehe das Urteil vom Gericht da ist. Könnte man ja auch warten und gucken, ob sich die EU entscheidet, ob es eine neue Richtlinie geben soll oder nicht. Das ist auch noch nicht so ganz klar. Die Kommissarin Malmström hat mal in einem schwedischen Medium, das ich leider nur über Google Translate lesen konnte, bezweifelt, ob es eine neue Richtlinie gibt. Jetzt gibt es aber auch in sechs Wochen oder so neue Wahlen, neue Kommissionen. Ob die das dann auch so sieht, steht völlig in den Sternen. Es ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass es im Sommer einen neuen Anlauf, eine neue Kommission gibt. Es ist nicht so, dass wir die Richtlinie für immer beerdigt haben. Sascha Lobo hat das so schön ausgedrückt. Das sind alles Zombie, diese Abwehrkämpfe. Das kommt alles immer wieder. Die Frage ist nur, in welchem Gewand. Und auch in Deutschland wird das wiederkommen. Es ist die Frage, wer sich regierungsintern durchsetzen kann und auf wen, nicht nur wir mit unserer ablehnenden Seite, sondern auch die Sicherheitsbehörden, die da auch sehr viel Lobbydruck ausüben, wer sich durchsetzen kann. Ob es jetzt eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung leiht, ein Quick Freeze Plus oder was es da alles an Namen gibt, geben wird. Das werden wir in den nächsten Wochen sehen. Und nicht nur in den Parlamenten, auf unseren Publikationsmöglichkeiten, gegebenenfalls auf der Straße, sondern natürlich auch hier auf der Logbuch Netzpolitik begleiten.
Also kurz zusammengefasst, kurzfristig auf jeden Fall Entspannung.
Die Schlacht ist gewonnen, der Krieg geht weiter.
Der Krieg geht auch weiter im Internet. Und zwar da, wo es keine bösen Hacker abzuwert gibt, macht man sich die Infrastruktur selber kaputt, indem man fehlerhafte Software einspielt. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt so sehr ein Kernthema, aber ich dachte, es wäre trotzdem ganz wertvoll, mit einer netzpolitischen Perspektive darauf zu schauen. Der Heartbleed-Bug, ein einfacher Programmierfehler, der von vielen Reviewern dann nicht weder im Vorfeld noch im Nachgang gesehen wurde. In der OpenSSL-Bibliothek hat eine schon beeindruckend große Zahl an Servern auf eine Art und Weise einer Sicherheitsschwankung unterworfen, die man so bis vor Kurzem noch nicht gesehen hat. Kurz gesagt war einfach der angeblich verschlüsselte Zugang so unverschlüsselt. Also er war schon verschlüsselt, aber man konnte eben über die Ausnutzung dieses Heartbleed-Bugs an kritische Informationen herankommen, bis hin zu dem eigentlichen privaten Schlüssel, den der Server verwendet. Das ist halt doppelt bekloppt, weil das eben dann auch theoretisch und auch praktisch das Zurückentschlüsseln vorher aufgezeichneter Datenströme ermöglicht. Wir erinnern uns ja in dieser ganzen NSA-Debatte, waren ja immer von diesen riesigen Speichermengen die Rede. Und warum speichern die denn das alles, vor allem wenn denn das alles verschlüsselt ist? Na ja, falls man mal den Schlüssel rausbekommt und so weiter. Also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es zumindest eine zweiwöchentliche geheime Vorratsdatenspeicherung der Dienste gibt. Das hat sich glaube ich in England zumindest so angefühlt. Tempora. Tempora. Wann das? Zwei Wochen, habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung. Vier Wochen, irgendeinen Zeitraum. Also jetzt nicht mehrere Jahre, das bezog sich nur auf den unverschlüsselten Teil. Aber in dem Moment, wo man halt voll alles mitschneidet und dann eben auch noch über diesen Heartbleed-Exploit an private Schlüssel eines Servers kommt, wie zum Beispiel google.com oder yahoo.com, die alle durchaus betroffen waren, dann kann man im Prinzip diesen kompletten verschlüsselten, mitgeschnittenen Datenverkehr später wieder zurück übersetzen.
Außer, wenn Perfect Forward Secrecy eingesetzt wird.
Außer, was genau, was aber leider nicht so verbreitet ist. Wenn man sich mal die gängigen SSL-Testing-Tools hernimmt, die abklappern, was den Server so machen. Mit HTTPS alleine ist es ja nicht getan. Es gibt da viele Optionen. Und eins davon ist eben, wie du schon sagst, diese Perfect Forward Secrecy, eine Methode der Abwandlung der Verschlüsselung, die eben verhindert, dass eben mitgeschnittenes später nach Bekanntwerdung eines privaten Schlüssels noch entschlüsselt werden kann. Wer das gemacht hat, dem kann man auf die Schulter klopfen und sagen, gut gemacht. An der Stelle habt ihr euch im Prinzip rückversichert.
Na ja, du musst trotzdem deinen Private Key ändern und deine User zum Passwort ändern.
Mussten ändern, aber zumindest ist dieses Mitschneiden nicht mehr ein Problem. Aber auch das ist eben eine Option, die selten zum Einsatz kommt. Dafür gibt es eigentlich keinen guten Grund, warum wir das machen. Aber letzten Endes ist das alles eine Frage des Konfigurationsaufwands, den ein Administrator einmalig betreiben muss. Es ist nicht so, dass man dazu zusätzliche Rechnerkapazitäten oder besonders teure Software noch einsetzen muss. Es ist einfach nur eine Frage der Awareness beim Setup der Technik.
Danke, Tim. Ich ändere dann mein Logbuch Netzpolitik Passwort, wenn es dann irgendwann mal SSL gibt.
Ja, das ist auch alles gar nicht so einfach in dieser Welt, HTTPS zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt alle eure Passwörter geändert, nachdem ihr euch versichert habt, dass euer jeweiliger Dienst auf der anderen Seite dann Heartbleed auch gefixt hat und gegebenenfalls ein neues Schlüsselpaar installiert hat.
Ja, das ist natürlich das nächste Problem, dass eben auch das Beheben es gibt da ja noch viele Stufen dahinter. Also bis das wirklich auch komplett behoben ist, muss im Prinzip nicht nur dieser private Schlüssel geändert werden, sondern es muss im Prinzip das komplette Zertifikat neu aufgesetzt werden. Man kann nicht auf Basis der alten Einstellung einfach was Neues generieren, weil das dann immer noch demselben Schlüssel basiert. Und dazu kommt auch noch, dass eben manche Browser, wie zum Beispiel Google Chrome, da habe ich das selber schon nachvollziehen können, teilweise eben mit diesen alten Zertifikaten weiterarbeiten, obwohl sie offiziell als revoked gelten. Also als, das wollen wir jetzt nicht mehr verwenden.
Weil man OCSP erst einschalten muss in Chrome.
Also das Protokoll zum Abfragen.
Online-Zertifikat-Status.
Kann man das überhaupt einschalten?
Ja, in Chrome gibt es ein Setting. Ich glaube, in Firefox ist es default an, bin mir aber nicht so sicher. Wobei es sich jetzt auch in dieser ganzen Welle gezeigt hat, das ist alles ein Graus. Je tiefer man guckt in diesem X509 und dieser Zertifikatsmafia und in diesem, wie wird Vertrauen im Internet überhaupt verifiziert, das lässt alles gruseln. Interessanter als die Paranoia und Boulevard-Meldungen, wir werden alle sterben, das Internet ist kaputt und nichts ist mehr sicher, waren ja auch die Niles oder nicht die Niles der NSA, die Security. Wie der Name in der NSA so schön sagt, herzustellen. Nicht nur für Behörden, die auch Open SSL nutzen, auch in den Staaten, sondern auch Firmen. Nur hat die NSA da zwei Hütte. Auf der einen Seite sollen sie, ähnlich wie das BSE, dafür zuständig sein, Threats im Internet zu analysieren, Schwachstellen zu finden, Hersteller und Anwender zu mehr Sicherheit zu verhelfen, solche Lücken zu schließen. Auf der anderen Seite, darüber haben wir jetzt seit Juni jede Menge gelernt, gibt es natürlich auch Operationen wie die Tailored Access Operation, die diese Sachen offensiv einsetzen, die auf jede Menge, eine Zahl, die da gesiert ist, Tausende Zero Days sitzen, Sicherheitslücken kennen, die öffentlich nicht bekannt sind und diese aktiv ausnutzen, um Computer zu infiltrieren. Wer sich da durchsetzt in der NSA? Gut, das werden wir leider öffentlich nie so wirklich nachprüfen können. Obama sagt, ja, nee, wir sind die Guten und wir fixen das eigentlich, außer es ist echt verdammt wichtig, dass wir das nicht tun. So ungefähr, außer es ist für die Nationale Sicherheit eben.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Ja, das ist auch, merkt man auch wieder, so ein generelles Problem. Also wenn man mal davon ausgeht, was ich jetzt hier noch nicht unterstellen will, weil ich weiß es einfach nicht, aber wenn man davon ausgeht, dass sie von diesem Bug Kenntnis hatten, nach der bisher bekannt gewordenen Politik, kann man davon ausgehen, so, okay, dann wussten sie es, dann haben sie es benutzt und das war's. Das heißt, anstatt darauf hinzuwirken, dass sich diese Sicherheitslücke, dass sie geschlossen wird, dass es bekannt wird, ja, macht man halt einfach, was man will und jetzt ist es halt so, dass natürlich im Prinzip jedem da der Zugang ermöglicht wurde. Es gab ja auch diese Bot-Netz, die in irgendeiner Form so den Eindruck gemacht hätten, weiß ja gar nicht, wer die betreibt, ja, kann genauso gut.
Diese EFF-Story, dass es da zwei IPs gab, von Bot-Netz, die versucht haben, IRC-Daten mitzuschneiden, der eigentlich SSL-verschlüsselt ist.
Ja, mit der Verdächtigung dazu, dass IRC-Abgrasen jetzt nicht unbedingt so bei Kriminellen so beliebt sei, das weiß ich alles nicht. Also es ist einfach mal wieder alles sehr unklar. So oder so sollte man vielleicht von vornherein sowieso häufiger mal seine Passwörter wechseln. Dieser Aufruf, irgendwie alle seine Passwörter zu ändern, wird nicht unbedingt dazu führen, dass das auch alle tun. Und von daher bleibt das Netz auch weiterhin etwas einen bestimmten Sicherheitsschwankungen unterworfen.
Sicherheitsschwankungen geht immer ins Internet. Das ist ja keine Blümchenwiese, wie wir auch erfahren haben. Ich meine, nicht nur sind es Aktionen der Geheimdienste, um solche Lücken zu finden und aktiv auszunutzen. Das passiert auch. Nicht nur von Diensten, sondern auch von anderen Kriminellen. Und das ist eins der Grundprobleme, was wir schon beim Staatstreuern hier in Deutschland immer gesagt haben. Wenn ihr Lücken ausnutzen wollt, dann bedeutet das, ihr findet welche und sagt aber nicht Bescheid, dass die auch gefixt werden und ihr verwendet die sogar selber. Das macht das Internet im Endeffekt mehr unsicher als mehr sicher. Denn wenn ihr die Lücke findet, hat die auch China gefunden und dann hat die auch der, keine Ahnung, Botnet-Betreiber aus sonst wo gefunden und im Zweifel werden viele Millionen End-User-Devices damit geowned, um Viagra oder Nigeria-Spam zu verschicken, nur damit ihr in eurem, wie auch immer, das aktuelle Owning-Programm der NSA wieder heißt, das verwenden könnt. Oder eben auch in Deutschland. Wir haben ja auch Staatsdrojaner, die natürlich auch auf Zero Days beruhen.
Na ja, aber in Deutschland wird ja alles gut, weil wir haben ja Untersuchungsausschüsse und die finden die Wahrheit heraus, wenn jemand mal was Böses getan hat. Wir berichteten auch hier schon, es gibt ja einen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, der ja jetzt schon mal gleich wieder tolle Neuigkeiten produziert hat. So, als erstes tritt dann erstmal der Vorsitzende zurück. Ich habe nicht so ganz verstanden, warum eigentlich.
Das hat niemand so ganz verstanden. Die Meldung tickerte so rein und wir so, hä, in der zweiten Sitzung, der hat sich gerade erst gegründet, der hat gerade erst diesen Vorsitz von diesem Ausschuss angetreten. Tritt, ich komme gerade nicht auf die Seite, aber Kleinen und Spinninger heißt ja gutem Mann, glaube ich. Tritt dann einfach mal zurück und zwar aus einer weirden Begründung. Ähm, ja, die Opposition, die wollen ja da diesen Edward Snowden vornehmen und das ist mir alles extrem unangenehm und da gibt es ja diesen internationalen Druck mit ähm, ja, diplomatischen Verwerfungen, den USA und so. Irgendwie ist mir das alles über den Kopf gewachsen. Äh, ich will nicht mehr. Gibt keinen Sinn, weil, dass die Opposition Sachen anders sieht und politischen Druck ausübt. Dafür sind die da. Das wusste er als Äh, Ausschussvorsitzender.
Ich hab ja keine Einblicke darin, aber das klingt für mich so ein bisschen wie, er hat einen Telefonanruf bekommen, den er nie in seinem Leben erhalten wollte. Ich weiß nicht, wer ihn angerufen hat. Aber nach dem Motto, es macht so ein wenig den Eindruck, als ob da jemand gesagt hätte, so was wie, äh... No. Es ist mir egal, welche Methode du anwendest, aber das Ergebnis davon muss sein, dass dieser Mensch nicht nach Deutschland kommt. Sonst... Und in dem Moment hat er einfach gesagt, da sitze ich jetzt lieber mit meinem Abgeordnetengehalt irgendwie in Rente gemütlich irgendwie rum und habe keine große Karriere gemacht, als dass ich mir die Nummer antue. So.
Ja, wurde ja auch vermutet, dass so was passiert ist. Er hat natürlich sofort abgestritten, dass Merkel oder irgendjemand anderes der Bundesregierung Druck auf ihn ausgeübt hätte.
Weil wenn er das sagen würde, dann hätte er die Konsequenzen wahrscheinlich auch schon.
Eine Karriere hat er aber schon. Er ist ja auch Vorsitzender des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums. Und es gibt Mutmaßungen im politischen Berlin. Die Stelle des BKA-Vorsitzenden wird frei. Der Jörg Zierke sollte das eigentlich schon lange nicht mehr sein. Die suchen händeringend nach einem Nachfolger. Und das steht an. Und Herr Benninger ist auch ehemaliger Polizeibeamter. Es ist nicht ganz ausgeschlossen, dass er eventuell auch damit liebäugelt, was er natürlich in der Öffentlichkeit auch sofort abstreitet. Das hat überhaupt gar nichts damit zu tun. Überhaupt ist in dem Ausschuss Party mit Edward Snowden. Eigentlich hat sich der Ausschuss ja geeinigt, den Gutemann befragen zu wollen. Die Details sind dann halt noch unklar. So wie wann und wo. Aber man hat schon mal eine politische Übereinkunft erreicht. Da geht es auch noch hin und her. Da kam es dann auch irgendwie zu Tumulten in der Sitzung. Und die Regierung ist natürlich sehr staats- tragend und USA-freundlich und so. Wir können den nicht einreißen lassen. Sonst reißt uns Obama den Arsch auf. Es gibt ein Auslieferungsabkommen und ein Auslieferungsgesuch, das wo auch rechtens ist. Und wenn der deutschen Boden betritt, dann können wir gar nicht anders als ihn ausliefern. Und auf der anderen Seite aber auch die Opposition, die sagt, Deutschland ist ein souveräner Staat und der gute Mann kann massiv zur Aufklärung beitragen. Wir sollten uns von nichts und niemand einschüchtern lassen und dem Menschen hier freies Geleit geben. Die Opposition hat angekündigt, so klang das zumindest durch, notfalls die Vorladung bis zum Bundesverfassungsgericht durchzuklagen mit ihren lieberweise zugestandenen Minderheitenrechten, die ja auch geändert wurden im Bundestag. Hier hatte das auch angesprochen. Zum Glück machen Linke und Grüne da Druck, den guten Edward doch noch in den Ausschuss und oder ins Land zu bekommen.
Die Frage ist natürlich, wenn er wirklich hier herkommt, darf er dann wieder zurück nach Russland?
Oder darf er dann direkt vom Reichstagsgebäude über Rammstein nach sonst wo hin?
Brasilien?
Nein, ich würde dann eher, es gibt ja Auslieferungsgesuchungen, also Guantanamo ist da glaube ich wahrscheinlich als Brasilien. Ob das so einfach ist, ich meine wir hatten Glenn Greenwald jetzt zu Gast, Laura Poitras ist hier, der Jake ist hier und Sarah Harrison. Und für die scheint das hier Utopia zu sein, weil hier alles gut ist und der Internetfreiheitskampf ist gewonnen. Für uns stellt sich das alltäglich ein bisschen anders dar, es ist ganz schön was zu tun. Glenn Greenwald hat immerhin, das ist schon mal unbegreiflich, dass wir uns überhaupt Sorgen machen, dass zwei Journalisten zu einer Preisverleihung nach New York City fliegen von Berlin aus und wir uns fragen, gibt es einen Live-Ticker, kommen die jetzt rein, was passiert jetzt? Werden die sofort weggeknastet? Denen ist zum Glück nichts passiert. Glenn Greenwald und Laura sind am Freitag gut in New York angekommen. Ohne Hessel. Aber das ist die freie Welt im Jahr 2014. Wir stellen uns ernsthaft die Frage, ob Journalisten dafür, dass sie Journalismus machen, nicht sofort eingeknastet werden.
Im Zentrum der freien Welt.
Im Zentrum der freien Welt, in ihrem Heimatland. Zumindest Glenn ist Bürger, ich glaube Laura ist auch Bürger.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ist ja auch Amerikanerin.
Und, ja, Edward Snowden, der würde ja auch gerne irgendwann mal seine Familie wiedersehen, aber dass der amerikanischen Staatsboten betritt, ohne sofort weggeknastet zu werden, ist leider ziemlich unwahrscheinlich.
Also jetzt ist ja auch noch der Pulitzer-Preis verliehen worden an Washington Post und Guardian für die Berichterstattung der NSA-Affäre. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern die da jetzt konkret Green-Wald-Portraits mit einbeziehen.
Das mit dem...
Aber welchen Preis haben sie denn jetzt eigentlich bekommen?
Pulitzer-Preis, ach so, das war jetzt erst... Das hab ich noch gar nicht gesehen. George-Polk-Preis, von dem ich vorher nie gehört habe. Genauso wie dem Remzmer Liberty Award, der am Donnerstag verliehen wurde hier in Berlin, von dem ich vorher auch noch nie gehört habe.
Das ist eine gute Gelegenheit, für diese ganzen Awards endlich mal wahrgenommen zu werden. Sucht man sich dann auch den passenden Leute aus dafür. Es geht dann mehr um die Awards als um die Leute.
Aber Glenn hat den Liberty Award ja gar nicht bekommen, sondern nur die Laudatio gehalten. Aber immerhin, er war in Berlin und hat dann auch ein paar Songs, auch gleich noch mal Fazzeit und Tagesspiegel, ein paar Interviews gegeben, in denen er unter anderem auf die Absurdität hinweist. Es gibt in Deutschland einen Ausschuss, der will die untiefen internationalen Überwachungsgeheimdienst-Machinerie ergründen. Und wie kann man sich überhaupt die Frage stellen, Edward Snow nicht anhören zu wollen? Weil es gibt keinen anderen Menschen auf diesem Planeten, der sowohl dieses System so gut von innen kennt, der hat da zehn Jahre lang gearbeitet, der ist fucking Geheimdienstmitarbeiter die längste Zeit gewesen, als auch der hat noch nicht nur die Dokumente, die die Journalisten haben, sondern auch noch mehr Dokumente, die er noch nicht mal denen gegeben hat. Und er ist einer der wenigen Whistleblower, die sich trauen, da öffentlich auszusagen. Glenn weiß da richtigerweise darauf hin, also wenn der Ausschuss Edward nicht anhören will, warum haben sie sich dann überhaupt gegründet?
Also ich denke, die Post wird uns noch eine Weile beschäftigen. Und wir sind verharrende Dinge da, die da noch kommen. Ja, jetzt sind wir eigentlich noch durch. Jetzt haben wir noch ein bisschen Internet, Netzpolitische Folklore zu berichten. Es gab Big Brother Awards.
Ja, die, wie drück ich das aus? Negativpreise für Datenschutzverletzungen.
Ja, was wurde denn dieses Jahr für preiswürdig erachtet?
Ja, unter anderem, vielleicht fangen wir von vorn an. Die Big Brother Awards gibt es schon ewig, auch international. Und in Deutschland macht das seit vielen, vielen Jahren schon der damals FöBUD, jetzt Digitalcourage, und verleihen den Negativpreis an die größten Datensünder des Jahres. Und den Hauptpreis, oder den ersten Preis hat natürlich gleich mal das Bundeskanzleramt gewonnen. Für die konsequentes Nichtstun, ignorieren, bestreiten und auch die eigene bundesdeutsche Involviertheit in diese Überwachungsmaschinerie. Das ist, glaube ich, ein ziemlich no-brainer. Ein ziemlich no-brainer, genau wie es dieses Jahr das erste Mal einen Positiv-Award gibt. Jetzt komm mal runter bitte. Genau, für Julia und Winston aus dem Roman 1984. Der geht natürlich an den Herrn Edward Snowden. Wie sollte es auch anders sein?
Das heißt, der Negativpreis verleiht jetzt auch Positivpreise.
Der Negativpreis verleiht jetzt auch Positivpreise. Ja, und dann gibt es einen Haufen weitere Preise wie LG für Smart TVs, die die angeguckten Serien und Filme mal eben nach Hause telefonieren. Die Computer Sciences Corporation, CSC, die hier auch schon öfters mal angesprochen wurde, diese Firma aus dem Umfeld der amerikanischen Verteidigungskonglomerats, diese ganzen Geheimdienstmaschinerie, die ja auch in Deutschland einen Ableger haben, der natürlich komplett eigenständig ist und unabhängig, nur zufälligerweise denselben Namen trägt, und die dann hier so lustige Sachen wie den neuen elektrischen Personalausweis mit Biometrie zertifizieren.
Elektronisch, sogar elektronisch, nicht nur elektrisch.
Ja, der hieß ja mal, habe ich elektrisch gesagt? Der hieß ja mal neuer Personalausweis, elektronischer Personalausweis und Biometrie-Personalausweis, keine Ahnung. Da gibt es bestimmt bald auch noch lustige Stories mit Ausweisen, wenn ich mal einen Blick in die Glaskugel werfen darf.
2.0.
Genau, und unter anderem der Staatstrojaner, der ja seit neuer Fintfischstrojaner, der seit anderthalb Jahren vom BKA mal angeschafft wurde und die jetzt evaluieren, ob sie das Ding einsetzen dürfen oder nicht. Die Evaluation macht auch die CSC, GmbH. Die kriegen den SOS-Code oder Teile davon zu sehen und bewerten, ob der deutschen Recht oder bestimmten Vorgaben entspricht. Die Digitalcourage und die Big Brother Awards haben da mal ein bisschen gegraben und Zusammenhänge der deutschen CSC und der amerikanischen Mutterfirma recherchiert. Unter anderem, dass die selber davon sprechen. Wir sind alles eine große Familie. Die Mitarbeiter von CSC Deutschland haben natürlich alle CSC.com-E-Mail-Adressen. Das wandert alles über die Infrastruktur in den Staaten und so. Die immer wieder beteuerte Unabhängigkeit mit der SS ist wohl nicht so weit her.
Mein Fernbus musste auch noch einen Preis beziehen. Ist denn dieses Jahr irgendjemand aufgetaucht und hat sich seinen Preis abgeholt?
Das habe ich leider nicht verfolgt. Das hätten wir, glaube ich, auf diesem Twitter mitbekommen. Es passiert ja auch sehr selten, dass die ihren Preis tatsächlich abholen.
Also bei meinem Fernbus war es die Ausweispflicht, also wenn man da mitreisen will, in dem Bus seinen Ausweis zu zeigen hat, wie man das von Flugzeugen ja auch schon kennt. Also man kann nicht einfach anonym reisen, warum auch immer. Und generell die Technik der Cloud-Integration in Autos, ein Thema, glaube ich, was uns in den nächsten Jahren noch sehr beschäftigen wird, gerade auch im Hinblick auf die durchaus auch zu erwartende Fortsetzung von Mautideen, Ausweitung auf Pkw etc., also die volle Erfassung des Verkehrs, einschließlich der demnächst gegebenenfalls sogar anstehenden Verpflichtung zur Datenübertragung. Also es gibt ja jetzt auch auf EU-Ebene eine Regelung, die vorschreibt, dass Autos, jetzt komme ich gerade ein bisschen ins Schwimmen, was genau die Vorschrift ist, aber das können wir später vielleicht nochmal nachreichen, aber der Trend geht auf jeden Fall dahin, die ohnehin schon existierenden GPS-Systeme so für Notfallsituationen zu nutzen und dementsprechend dann auch Vorrichtungen vorzusehen, die Positionen dann im Unfallmoment elektronisch zu übermitteln. Wir wissen alle, in dem Moment, wo solche Techniken vorrätig sind, ist es dann eben schnell getan, eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung quasi im Auto vorzuhalten, nicht wegen Steuerbetrugs etc. und wegen der Sicherheit etc. bis hin zu einer Online-Übermittlung. Das sind alles, glaube ich, solche Szenarien, die da bald drohen. Und das wurde hier mit diesem Award dann auch schon mal perspektivisch ausgerichtet, nehme ich an.
Vielleicht kriegen wir dann den ADAC fürs Internet.
Ja, Metadaten sind auch böse, hat der Big Brother Award beschlossen. Ich spreche ja schade, das ist ja eigentlich mein Lieblingswort gewesen. Ich mag ja Metadaten an sich, nur die Erfassung derselben ist halt durchaus problematisch.
Ich mag Metadaten auch in meinen eigenen Dateien. Aber das, was Metadaten von Kommunikationsmetadaten da draußen rumgeistert, das ist doch noch sensibler als die eigentlichen Inhalte.
Ja, insofern ganz wertvoll, dass das auch nochmal erwähnt wurde an der Stelle, dass diese Aussage mit, es sind ja nur Metadaten nochmal umgedreht wird. Es sind vor allem Metadaten und das ist das Problem da dran. Gut, Andre, ich denke, wir haben es, oder?
Klar, Ausgabe 100 im Sack.
Ausgabe 99. Für die 100 haben wir uns noch was Schönes einfallen lassen. Lasst euch überraschen. Aber es geht jetzt, sagen wir mal, noch in der nächsten Zeit etwas seichter vonstatten, was die Veröffentlichungszyklen betrifft, denn es nahen jetzt einige schwierige Terminlagen. Das ist Ostern, das ist die anstehende Republik. Das wird hier, sagen wir mal, den Veröffentlichungszyklus etwas in Mitleidenschaft ziehen, aber danach geht es sicherlich wieder wie gewohnt weiter.
Aaron Linus hat nichts damit zu tun?
Nicht unmittelbar.
War es wert.
Alles klar. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Tschüss und bis bald.